hey crazies there's this thing that
mathematicians and physicists like to
say math is the language of the universe
you've probably heard it so many times
that you've just accepted it as truth
but rule number eight here at the
science Asylum is question everything is
math really the language of the universe
answering this question is gonna take
some time and we need to be careful so
let's start with a simpler question is
math even a language what is the
language anyway that's two questions but
I'll see what I can do we need to know
what a language is before we can decide
if math is what a language is a complex
system of words and symbols either
spoken or written used by a particular
community as a means of communication
okay so it makes sense why something
like English German Arabic or eaglet and
pay would be languages but what about
math is math a complex system of words
and symbols yes
either spoken or written mostly written
but yes is it used by a particular
community definitely yes as a means of
communication whoa maybe the purpose of
math is just to communicate ideas to
each other math is used as a tool to
make predictions about the actual world
of course that requires us to also ask
is the sole purpose of a language to
communicate I would say no and I think
most of you would agree with me language
can also be used as a tool in the right
hands language can be used to inspire or
to lighten the mood or to strengthen
someone's resolve in the wrong hands it
can be used to hurt someone to destroy
their reputation and still fear or even
control others so I don't think the fact
that math is used as a tool is a
disqualifier the definition of a
language doesn't even require that
communication be the sole purpose it
said as a means of not for the purpose
of I'm still not entirely convinced
though we need another test something
else we know about languages is that you
can translate between them so if we can
translate between math and something
like English then we might have a decent
argument oh you want to start an
argument well let me tell you that kind
of argument when I say argument I don't
mean one of those fights over politics
or whatever an argument is more of a set
of reasons or ideas in support of a
conclusion in an effort to persuade
others to the same conclusion
a point made by a logical individual in
a column discussion people rarely think
logically in political conversations
anyway let's get translation to try when
you translate from any language to
another some meanings can get lost but
as long as most of the ideas translate I
think we're good we said earlier that
languages are made of words and symbols
and that math has plenty of symbols the
most recognizable symbol is probably
this one the equal sign but the word
equal is more of a name than a meaning a
good direct translation of the equal
sign would be is the same S which is a
phrase rather than a word but that's
okay
translations don't have to be a one word
to one word correspondence this English
eight word sentence is six words in
Polish but ten words in Albania math is
just much more concise it takes fewer
symbols to contain a meeting except you
don't find a mathematics option in
Google Translate so what gives is it a
language or not hmm I don't think we can
judge by Google Translate it only has
103 languages and there are over 6900
spoken languages currently in use not to
mention all the dead languages my point
is the Google Translate is far from
complete so let's try a translation on
our own math uses the Latin letters and
the Greek letters both uppercase and
lowercase and a whole collection of
other unique symbols which is probably
why people are so afraid of it all of
those symbols have at least one meaning
but many have multiple meanings that we
have to understand by context for
example an uppercase v could be the bulk
elastic constant which represents how
rigid something is in response to
pressure changes like air in response to
a sound wave passing through it but an
uppercase B could also be the strength
of a magnetic field the kind of thing
you might imagine is around a bar magnet
this is pretty typical of languages
though take the English word duck for
example it can refer to a type of bird
or the action of suddenly lowering your
head words with multiple meanings are so
common there's a word to describe them
hominem so multiple meanings doesn't
disqualify math as a language either
let's try to translate a whole sentence
say you've got a simple mathematical
sentence like this it makes use of six
symbols Delta s
equals F I and - we've already seen
equals means is the same as Delta means
change it and s means position or where
something is the F and I are only
subscripts they just describe the symbol
they're attached to so they're more like
adjectives than nouns f stands for final
or at the end I stands for initial or at
the beginning and minus means the
difference between so this mathematical
sentence reads the change in where
something is is the same as the
difference between where that something
is at the end and where that something
is at the beginning seems like a pretty
illogical statement to me you can do
this with other mathematical sentences -
Newton's second law Ohm's law even
Einstein's equation like any other
translation though you lose some meeting
mathematical sentences say a lot more
than their English translation you're
also going to have a really hard time
translating the other way this English
sentence has no translation in math
although I'm willing to hear arguments
in favor of this one translations
grammar adjectives and nouns sounds a
lot like a language to me and as a
scientist I use it to communicate with
people all the time
so is math a language I would argue yes
and just like any other language it's
governed by a set of rules those rules
are just a lot more absolute than a
typical language and they're built from
the ground up this gives math some extra
power if you know how to use it which
brings us back to our original question
is math really the language of the
universe okay this one's a little
trickier if math really is the language
of the universe then anything we
calculate should have meaning which
seems to be true of counting we take
something like this and call it 1 and
something like this and call it 2 we can
put them together and call that 3 we can
put three of those threes together and
call it 9 these seem like pretty solid
rules and they seem like they apply to
the universe but we're going to learn a
lot more if we try to disprove it we
need to find a number that doesn't have
any meetings hmm there are tons of
calculations I could just make up but no
one would ever expect those to have
anything maybe something people would
expect to have meaning what about
density oh that's brilliant I'm so glad
you're a clone of me density measures
the compactness of a substance an easy
way to calculate it is to take the mass
and divide it by the volume in this
tells you something about the spacing
between the molecules it makes sense for
things like ice or rubber or helium gas
or air wait a minute
density measures the compactness of a
substance air is a mixture of a bunch of
different things mostly nitrogen and
oxygen but still a mixture it's a pretty
uniform mixture though so I can
understand arguments in favor I'm
calling it one substance but what about
this
can I just measure mass on a scale and
volume using a beaker and then divide
the two numbers I suppose you could but
that number wouldn't really say anything
it's what we call an average density
which might make sense for a uniform
mixture like air but not for this rubber
ducky it's made of two substances rubber
and air and they're definitely not
uniform throughout the ducky so while it
might be a useful shortcut in a
calculation somewhere it doesn't
actually tell you anything about the
compactness of that ducky it's a number
that only exists on paper it has no
physical meaning and that's another
reason it can't be used to explain why
things float commenters anyway all
average values sit in this gray area
sometimes they have meaning and
sometimes they don't
meaning is what we're looking for in
science we're trying to understand deep
philosophical questions about our
existence like where did we come from
why are we here
science is about meaning it's about
language plus there are plenty of
statements that have meaning but don't
have a translation into math math alone
will never be enough no number will ever
answer those deep philosophical
questions not even 40 - math is not the
language of the universe even if we
wanted to personify the universe and say
it's trying to communicate with a
language which I would advise against
math would only be a small part of our
best translation of it so what do you
think does the universe work using math
or is it something we made up I'd like
to know in the comments thanks for
liking and sharing this video don't
forget to subscribe if you'd like to
keep up with us and until next time
remember it's okay to be crazy
in the last video we learned about the
lives of stars tournament response time
Ben bender mentioned that you can learn
a lot more from a star's life than just
its color and its age yes using optics
we can also learn what a star is made of
and how fast it's moving toward or away
from us you can also get distance
sometimes but that's a topic for another
video
iris and born told us kids that the
light coming from the Sun peaks in green
it's pretty weird but it's true in fact
it's very common for stars if you take
all the peak wavelengths from all of the
stars in the universe you get a greenish
color it just doesn't look green because
it's emitting the other colors too when
our eyes receive light of all colors it
still has to send that signal to our
brain but that looks like a jumbled mess
so your brain turns it all white to
create contrast in your field of view
yeah white is an illusion also a topic
for another video
miss physics wish she had studied more
astrophysics in her undergrad the
downside to university programs is
really all the non majors courses you
have to take to get a degree undergrad
took me five years and I still didn't
take all the undergrad physics courses I
should have I guess we'll just have to
learn things on our own
it's more fun that way anyway schools
and tents Graham Wilson asked if black
holes were frozen at Absolute Zero and
the answer is no for a while we had
these special laws for black holes but
eventually we realized that there does
the laws of thermodynamics black holes
have to obey the laws of thermodynamics
just like anything else even though that
might result in a few paradoxes future
video I agree with Jim Groth that how we
know what we know is very important
getting to see the process can make
science feel more doable to non
scientists and learning the history
behind it can help us understand the
obstacles we ran into along the way
which is why my advanced ebook is
written from a historical perspective
because even people who go into physics
like me need that history heated mode
Star Trek is the best reason to talk
about well three five nine a close
second would be that it's so low mass
that it almost isn't a star future video
okay one more thing before I go
YouTube has started these end card
annotations that work on mobile but
there's a twenty second time limit which
means that I can't use them these
comment responses are a few minutes long
I'm considering separating the comment
responses into their own video kind of
like how idea channel does it but I
didn't want to do that with
talking to you first pros it lets me use
the mobile annotations and it makes the
videos a little more shareable con it
separates the conversation which I'm
really hesitant about let me know your
thoughts your feelings about this in the
comments ok crazies thanks for watching
I'll see you next time
[Music]